and I'll stop that war mark my words
I'll stop that war in 24 hours
but we're in a position
the only way he could stop in 24 hours
would be to force Ukraine to fold I
can't think of any other way he could
end it in 24 hours
Mr President let me ask
serious question how do you stop that
war in 24 hours I know both and frankly
uh zielinski was very good because they
you know he was part of the phone call
and he said he didn't say anything wrong
to me the Democrat he could have gone in
grandstand and said well I felt
threatened I felt threatened he didn't
I get along with him I get along with
Putin it's it would have been much
easier to stop it before it started
Putin would have never done this would
have been much easier right now it's a
mess now they're hitting Kiev and
they're hitting all sorts of things that
weren't supposed to be hit right the
country is being decimated by the way
the deaths are far more than their
report you know when they say not if
you're waiting for the answer it's not
in here